[Music]
Kim Kardashian claps back at model tyson
beckford
I will cut you here's what happened this
photo of Kim was posted to a popular
Instagram account
Tyson left his two cents in the comments
writing quote she is not real doctor duh
pon her right hip sorry I don't care for
it personally you take pictures and if
they're not like perfect people just
like Bobby shame you and criticize you
and like for people to just think that's
okay is so frustrating Kim chimed in
with a cryptic response writing quote
sis we all know why you don't care for
it it's hardly the first time the 37
year old reality star has hit back at
her critics after Chloe grace Moretz and
Bette Midler commented
unenthusiastically on Kim's nude selfie
the brunette beauty wasted no time going
off on Twitter it's so bizarre to me
Kim's former brother-in-law Lamar Odom's
said this about his ex-wife Kim's sister
Chloe Kim tweeted or second or third
brothel referencing Lamar's 2015
hospitalization after he was found
unconscious at a Nevada brothel and of
course who can forget the feud between
Kim and Taylor Swift
in 2016 Taylor was upset after Kim's
husband Kanye West released his single
famous featuring this controversial
lyric I feel like me and Taylor my still
has six well I made that famous Kim
ignited a firestorm online posting
videos on snapchat of a phone call that
allegedly took place between Kanye and
Taylor to you as a friend everyone has
to just not be blasting people on social
media
[Music]